what if I told you that the highest
converting e-commerce emails use
practically zero design well in this
video I'm going to show you the exact
framework that I use to write great
e-commerce emails that puts money in
your client's pocket your own pocket and
requires absolutely no design skills but
before we dive in I do have a free gift
for you my course copyrighting Catalyst
it's a copyrighting guide with 63 cash
cow copyrighting tips that you can read
in 90 seconds or less each and get a ton
of free copyrighting value so if you are
just diving into copyrighting this is a
phenomenal resource for you to get going
go ahead and hit the link in the
description below give me your email
tell me where to send it and I'll have
it over to you ASAP absolutely free all
right let's dive into what we're here to
talk about first before I show you my
framework I need to tell you why I do
things the way that I do because this is
going to be controversial to how most
copywriters approach Ecommerce Brands
where you've subscribed to those big
e-commerce brands with lots of images
and designs and layering and and you're
a copywriter so you're like well I'm not
a designer I can't do those things well
I've gone the opposite route and I've
had tremendous success with the Ecom
brands that I've written for generating
hundreds of thousands of dollars using
this very controversial strategy of
plain text emails that's right a plain
text email a dream to a copywriter like
yourself I'm going to show you exactly
how I do it but first let me tell you
the benefits because your clients will
freak out right no doubt they're going
to be like what am I paying for for you
just a write copy and blah blah blah let
me give you some of the benefits that
you can quickly outline for my way of
doing Ecom Brands benefit number one is
deliverability a plain text email is way
more likely to land in somebody's
primary inbox instead of the spam or
promotions folder so when you're client
is struggling with clicks or open rates
or sales you need to check their
deliverability and if they're doing
highly designed emails those are big red
flags to Google and Yahoo and other
people's filters that say this could
potentially be a promotional or spam
email which candidly most e-commerce
emails are promotional emails but we
want to bypass those filters with great
deliverability a plain text email is way
less likely to trigger a promo or spam
filter which means your open rates will
go up your click rates will go up and
your sales will go up the second benefit
is you have a more personal touch to
your emails as I'm about to show you in
the email that we're going to write
together me and you today you're going
to notice that it feels less like
corporate jargon trying to sell you
something and more like a personal
one-on-one connection and if you know me
you know that the first thing you sell
is yourself then your product no matter
how big your brand is it's humans buying
from other humans so the more personal
your emails can feel the bigger the win
again I'll explain more as we write the
email and benefit number three is the
automatic email mobile optimization most
people read on their mobile but most
designers design on a desktop and so you
have to do a lot of formatting and
textures and sometimes the mobile
doesn't look right so even though you
intended for this highly designed
beautiful email a lot of times it breaks
on mobile or it doesn't look good on
desktop it's hard to get both to look
right and with the pl text email it's
way more automatic you save way more
time and you spend more time creating
compelling emails rather than just
adjusting margins and curring and
Banners and all things like that but I
know what you're going to ask el copy go
how am I going to convince my client of
these things even with these benefits
well if you can't convince them outright
to at least try it ask them to AB test
what I'm about to show you hey let's do
the way we've been doing emails highly
designed all that stuff and then let's
also try this method as an AB test to
see the open rates the clicks and the
sales whichever one gets better results
will keep doing really hard to argue
with sales at that point so use that to
convince your client that this is the
way to go all right now let's dive in on
how to actually write these emails so
you can make a lot of green stuff and
I'm not going to hold back this is
practically a free course right here all
right so let's dive in I'm going to take
you over to my laptop let's go ahead and
start recording all right and here's
what I'm recording right here on my
laptop you see that I've opened up a
Google doc that is a campaign calendar
which by the way the Google Doc and
everything that I'm about to show you
today I'm going to give you for free in
the link in the description below you
can just click the link you can have it
all for free the template I'm going to
show you another template a little bit
later but basically step one of writing
great Ecom emails is I like to make a
campaign calendar so I like to know what
I'm writing ahead of time that way with
the title and the formats and all that
stuff taken care of I can have a great
go-to strategy two you can also show it
to your client right so that's an added
benefit is you can show your client the
campaign calendar before you start
writing so here's my simple campaign
calendar okay so I have an email
overview and for the sake of Simplicity
I I just got a couple on here but
typically I'm sending two to three
emails per client which would be about
12 emails per month on average but right
here I'm just showing you as if I were
writing one a week okay so four emails I
got the email which I usually put the
subject line or or the or the direction
or whatever up top the campaign date so
this is for February
20125 right um and then I'm putting the
date that the email is going to go out
and I'm putting whether it's approved or
not approved okay a lot of you guys have
systems whether it's a SAA or trell or
whatever for your clients to approve
these things I like to keep it simple
honestly even my highest paying multi
thousand clients uh they love that I
just send them a Google doc right they
love that I just this is just straight
up a Google doc it's got my emails here
to the side which we'll write one
together uh over here and we just align
on this it's so easy cuz they could just
come in here and they could just leave a
comment and Bam they love that so it's
very very excellent this is so simple
the simpler you leave it on your clients
the better all right so down here I got
the brand overview I'm writing for one
of my favorite clients he lets me talk
about this stuff on the channel so I
like to use him a lot plus he's great
fantastic hope well Farms great client
of mine they uh they sell organic uh
animal-based Foods so like uh chicken
eggs chicken beef turkey pork all things
like that he's gotten his own organic
farm regenerative all that stuff great
client uh the goal for February is we're
going to drive net new subscriptions he
has a subscription box thank butcher box
and we're going to drive net new
subscriptions for my client the Persona
I like to keep this simple I know a lot
of people they go above and beyond
you'll notice that I keep things simple
because I really want to focus on
writing great content not dilly-dallying
around on systems all day right so my
Persona is uh typically a 35 to 45y old
right they have a little bit more money
they want to invest in their health 80%
is female who's buying so keep that in
mind uh upper middle class right
there're typically making $80 to
$150,000 a year somewhere is that as a
household income they are local they are
in North Georgia uh very health
conscious and they invest in uh working
out organic food yoga they have kids
married family okay so you got kind of
get the gist I don't need to dive so
much into that right I got the website
here as a link handy so that way I know
all right this is where I'm going and
then one thing I really like to keep on
my docs I typically hide this from the
clients but um I keep this for your sake
in here so you can have it on the
template I've got like six kind of go-to
Frameworks that I use to write these
emails um and you could take these this
is like unlimited I use these all day
long I really don't vary off from any of
these so this is going to be helpful for
you so email ideas what I'm trying to
figure out here is I'm trying to figure
out what four emails do I want to write
for the month okay and then get that
online so right we're building the
campaign calendar so these are some
ideas I could do an FAQ so let's say an
email subscriber ask a question I like
to reply to it in public hey tell me
about Bubble bu is it is is grass-fed
beef really better than just normal
organic beef well I may take that email
reply and I'll turn it into an email
email customer subscriber Adrien ask is
grassed beef really better than organic
beef and then I start answering the
question I turn it into a fun bantering
back and forth and Bam that's the email
so that's a great email that I use very
often behind the scenes so I'll tell a
short story about what's going on behind
the scenes at Hopewell Farms right so
I'll text my client his name is Phil and
I'll say Phil tell me about something
that happened this week send me a voice
memo life hack tell your clients to just
send you a voice memo instead of
emailing you back oh my gosh they send
those so much faster they're way faster
it's way easier for the client I mean
they are founders owners CEOs these guys
don't have time and they're not writers
they don't want to write up a whole
email of stories or hop on another call
just send me a voice memo well he tells
me a story I take his voice memo I copy
the voice memo off my phone right and I
put that transcript into chat GPT I have
it summarized it for me so I get it and
it cleans up the transcript for me and
then I look at the summary and Bam I
write that into an email current event
or breaking news uh especially in the
farm or the food industry I have a ton
of content to always be writing on
current event breaking news and things
like that you could just literally look
up what's going on in my industry in
fact this is what we're going to write
on today I I Googled just before this
some strategies on what on what we're
going to write about today and so we're
going to do a current event breaking
news I'll show you that uh a review riff
take a review that a customer left right
you could go to Google right now like I
could literally just go to Google hope
well Farms I can come down in here here
and I could just look at the reviews I
could just look at all the reviews in
here scroll down and just see if I see
anything that catches my eye I mean this
one star uh we were there a while ago to
pick up some meat leaving a one star due
to this POS older short chubby guy in a
backwards hat who thought yelling at his
daughter was appropriate I might turn
that into an email that sounds pretty
funny right anything like that I bought
a turkey and the brisket I tell you wow
great quality the best okay that's
that's got to be an email this is the
subject line right here wow great
quality the best you see how she's so
that's a great
way this is hilarious it's a great way
to get an email okay so a review riff I
also like to do a Reddit riff I like to
go in Reddit and see what people are
talking about in my industry organic
health food things like that and see
what questions they have and then I'll
Reddit uh and then I'll review and Riff
on the comments right the comments are
typically pretty crazy super fun uh the
next one is a transformation I like to
tell transformation of clients right so
before I was buying hope well Farms
right I was probably slightly overweight
I was feeling really guilty about my
canva bowls my Chipotle seed oil bowls
and then after right you guys just
deliver it every week I'm cooking more
at home I'm in better shape blah blah
blah right so that's a good ab
transformation and then the last one is
US versus them I typically use this one
a lot so brand Enemy being like seed
oils big Pharma non-organic food just
unhealthy crap all this Stu
uh so typically you just find something
that you're picking on that cannot
compare to the quality of your product
uh and then bam you go from there so
honestly you could take one of these and
like come up here and like change this
out to current event you could turn this
one into an Us Versus Them you could
turn this one into a review riff right
all this stuff so now let's say we're
going to do a current event email one
current event okay so I'm going to take
that and from there I I'm now going to
outline the rest of my emails for the
month I'm going to start getting some
ideas for them uh and I'm going to start
writing some content right once you have
the ideas it's way easier to write all
right so now let's go to step two which
is write the email so to write the email
I'm going to give you the exact
framework that I use I like to use a tab
right here and the exact framework that
I like to use is called the slow
framework SLO what that stands for is
story lesson offer I know a lot of these
like e-commerce gurus out here are
always like Pas and Ada and they so good
all this four Ps and I love the slow
framework and the reason I like this is
because it keeps people engaged more
than just selling them they continue to
open your emails because they're
entertaining so I start with a short
story right I'm like riffing on
something that seems very enjoyable I
then pivot to a lesson or more like the
bridge to my offer and then I make the
offer so let's let's do this let's
actually write an email together and
I'll show you how I use the slow
framework SLO okay so back on the
campaign calendar I I talked about we're
going to do a current event so a little
bit earlier I literally went to Google
and I just typed in like breaking news
uh Farms USA right I typed this
in and I didn't get much and so then I
mean I I typically like to see like
what's what's actually trending right
what's on New York Jets could have had
top okay so like this is obviously not
good enough okay bird flu Illinois Cas
is about what you should know virus
spreads okay what's this bird
flu bird flu cases spread of am
concerning mutation bird flu Okay blah
blah blah all right so there's a bird
flu now let me see is there bird flu
Georgia
Farms okay chicken Farmers on alert from
bird flu found in second commercial
flock over 100,000 Ducks wow Aven and
and then bam this is the article I found
so obviously I I clicked over here Aven
search clues us poultry as address
contamination of raw food and then they
talk about uh Georgia outbreak poultry
Farms things like this okay so now I've
got some breaking news this is a serious
threat to Georgia's number one industry
and livelihoods of thousands of
Georgians okay now I've got some
breaking news that I can turn into an
email so I texted my client and I said
hey have you been affected by this bird
flu and he said no we're not affected at
all we don't run like a factory we're
very organic very natural so it's a lot
easier for us to not be affected I said
perfect fantastic okay he's like yeah I
got I got texted by that a couple times
people ask me if we have chicken and
things like that so I turned that into
an email okay so let me show you how
that email could look like I'll start
with the body typically I like to write
the the actual email itself and then and
then kind of Riff on the subject line I
know that's opposite to people but a lot
of times I'll actually end up writing
something that I think is so good it
becomes the subject line so I might do
something like this where I turn it into
a story where it says um I got a text
from a buddy
yesterday let's take this bold off I got
a text from a buddy
yesterday it says now this is how my
client likes to write Phil do you
have any chicken eggs I need protein
all right so we're having fun my client
is very fun he's very optimistic um he
enjoys us a lot so I like to do stuff
like this for him okay Phil do you have
any protein eggs chicken okay so now I'm
telling a story you see how I started
this like I didn't just be like hey guys
we have chicken available I know there's
like bird flu and stuff like that no I
didn't that stuff that stuff is like
good I probably make some short-term
sales but remember I'm trying to build
long-term relationships with my client
with my client's people and so I'd like
to tell a story because it keeps them
opening not just this email but the next
email and the next email and the next
email cuz they know it's going to be fun
it's going to be entertaining I'm not
just Hard Sell Hard Sell Hard Sell This
is the opposite of most Ecom Brands
they're just Hard Sell Hard Sell and
that's why they're so dependent on
discounts and Deals and and all that
offers and bonuses and premiums because
people don't want to buy their crap any
other time than when they're doing
discounts and deals but the way I write
it makes it so fun and engaging that
they're open and that emails whether
they're buying or not and chances are
makes it a lot more likely that they buy
I know cuz I made a lot of money doing
this all right so I got a text from a
buddy yesterday Phil do you have any
eggs do you have any chicken eggs or
protein and I told
him my man let's do this my man I am all
wiped
out let's write some of this I'll speed
this up for you and we we'll get rocking
and rolling
money from me over the
last since this bird flu
thing this is where I insert the
breaking news okay my man I'm all wiped
out because everybody's been buying from
me over the last few days from this bird
flu thing and then I pivot over to uh
I'm going to chime in with the breaking
news which is going to kind of be the
bulk of my email if you haven't heard
I'm talking to my email sub subcriber
there has been a massive case of bird
flu going around all these Georgia
Farms which is why you can't find barely
any chicken
eggs or other good
stuff at your local grocery
store and then we'll do this but fear
not we're having tons of fun here okay
but fear
not but fear
not farmer Phil is here and then I'm I'm
going to Pivot I'm making it funny cuz I
just said I got wiped out
actually I don't have
chicken but I do have
what you really
want
protein why settle for
chicken I'll take that down settle for
chicken
[Music]
when you can have
beef pork
steaks turkey
burgers I'm doing this cuz it's fun you
obviously kind of getting the vibe I'm
getting into this a little bit why
settle for chicken when you can have
beef pork steaks turkey burgers which is
actually included in your Farm Fresh
weekly box
subscription okay so now I'm pivoting to
the offer all right this is the the
short lesson here where I kind of told
the story my buddy my buddy texted me
about the bird flu thing I'm talking
about the bird flu thing I inserted that
I could Riff on this a lot longer but
for the sake of brevity in doing this
email I'm going to keep it to where it's
at okay farmer Phil is here actually I
don't have any chicken ha but but I do
have what you really want protein okay
so that's my lesson my lesson here is
I'm kind of Shifting it over to the you
don't really want chicken you want
protein okay protein is what's good for
you so wat set up for chicken when you
can have beef pork steaks turkey burgers
what is actually included in your farm
uh um which is actually included in your
Farm Fresh weekly
box that's exactly why I don't
have any more chicken because I
prioritize my subscribers
first maybe you would have got some
chicken but either way now is the
perfect
time to
subscribe because I'm also and I'm going
to make an offer because I'm also
offering your first box free when you
subscribe within the next 24 hours
typically I run these by the client he
lets me do stuff like this but you want
to have a list of offers that you go
back and forth just click the link
below notice that deadline I gave there
with the offer I love you got to have a
deadline with an offer so what do they
get and how long until they get it so
just click the link
below throw the Box in your cart and
voila
we will have it to you within 2 days at
your doorstep cool and then I put the
link
here uh obviously I can make this like
more engaging like I'm not going to
re-edit it typically my first go is
probably 80% of what I land on then I'll
re-edit it kind of tighten it up a
little bit change the transitions but
you get it up like even if I were to
fire this off right now it's honestly
you probably do really well so in that
we'll have it to you within two days
blah blah blah
hope you enjoy
this your
friend farmer Phil you enjoy this your
friend farmer Phil PS We Are
exclusive to Hall County which is a
county there in North Georgia I like to
add that in there uh to make it more
exclusive tight on the offer so as you
see there I started with a story this is
the SLO framework I started with the
story I went to the lesson
uh which could also just be seen as some
like transitionary period you don't have
to teach something but it's more like
it's more prepping them for the offer
I'm transitioning from I'm having fun to
like this is what you really want and
then I make the offer or I'm having fun
I'm going to address your problem then I
make the offer so slow the story lesson
offer this is how I actually do the SLO
framework so now we've got our email
written te uh candidly I like to take
this so let me see let's let's figure
out the um subject lines so okay so like
this line
actually I'll probably take this right
here and turn this
chicken eggs I
need
protein right that's going to be a super
fun subject line he likes that
stuff click inside for juicy details all
right like get him the call to action
super fun chicken eggs Protein that's
exactly why I like writing the email
because chances are I'm going toite
something in here that's eye-catching
that's fun instead of just like last
chance 24 hours again it's long-term
relationships that we're building okay
all right the last thing is one of two
things you could either take this email
copy and paste it into your clients's
clavio and ship it out right as is or
mail champ or whatever you guys are
using you can just copy and paste this
email send it out I like to send it by
the way from the owner so this will come
from Phil at Hopewell Farms or you know
if you're sending emails for somebody
else Jeff Jim shark or whatever like I
like to do those things because I make
it personal coming from somebody now
this is the last part if your client is
absolutely against zero design like I'm
not going to send a plain text emails
right I then created a canva template
for you that takes absolutely no design
skills whatever here's what it is it's
this canva template and at the very top
it's literally an image and the logo and
then the rest is plain text that's it
okay so if they're really against it
this is where I will offer some sort of
design so now I've got this design here
which honestly it's just like I took a
picture of a steak which you can change
it to chicken or whatever uh I put like
a little Banner over it right like a
little color Banner or you could do like
you could put the transparency lower uh
right you could do something like that
that's that's basically what you do so
that way I put the logo on top that's it
and then in Cana you can literally just
go in there search for a a picture of
chicken or whatever and then I copy and
paste the email in there that is
literally it so you don't have to do
anything other than that like
transparency down put the logo wherever
that you can get it change the picture
and that's it that literally takes no
design you were just adding a picture
and the logo literally it that way your
client's happy they're like okay I'm
getting some kind of design again you AB
test it from there I use this template
for any Ecom brand that hates the plain
text thing plain text is best but even
if you do one image it'll still get good
deliverability just not slatter with
images everywhere that's it that is
exactly how I write Ecom emails I build
a calendar okay I outline that calendar
I use the SLO framework on practically
every single email taking one of those
email ideas that I showed you in the
beginning we wrote an email live we put
that into either a plain text or the
most basic design ever I send it to my
client to approve which by by the way
you could send this canva link over to
your client to approve you could do that
if you want to uh or you can just send
the Google Doc again my client loves the
Google Doc it's great with it and then I
put the I put the emails in their clavo
and they're good to go so this is a very
simple way and highly profitable to
write Ecom emails you don't have to do
all these fancy things that everybody
else talks about this is really great
your clients will love it you'll get to
write more your clients will make a lot
more money you'll make a lot more money
and we're all happy if you enjoyed this
email I would ask you please hit the
like button and the Subscribe button to
show me that you want me to create more
free content just like this so you can
continue putting money in your pocket
and your client's Pockets become a
highly successful copywriter and we can
help each other I'm so grateful for you
thank you so much for watching I hope
this was helpful and I'll catch you on
the next one
[Music]